[Applause]
you Jezebel don't have the guts to face
the better god I never catch you Cates
you open your eyes I come at you by
Christ
so the key and exorcism is not what
people think in the movies it's not just
running in and throwing some holy water
and wade into crucifix and say it out
it's getting to this wounded angry part
of the person and resolving their issues
so that the evil attached to it has
nothing to hang on to anymore
[Music]
I don't walk around talking to demons I
I interrogate them when I'm actually
doing an exorcism I won't talk to a
demon outside of an exorcism but once
the exorcism starts there's a limited
context in which you allow a demon to
spit to get the information you need to
proceed with the exorcism
[Music]
in the last 30 years Larsson claims to
have exercised over 6,000 demons Jesus
on average she conducts 20 seminars a
month and has lectured in 80 countries
worldwide
[Applause]